really weird jimmy dore story that i  thought was satire i guess jimmy dore is  thinking about running for president  with the people's party which doesn't  have ballot access in any states and  says that ralph nader is going to be  advising his campaign  that's that's the story that i mean it's  uh it seems like it would be satirical i  saw a hilarious article saying  jimmy dore would be the most popular  comedian to run for president is like is  that meaningful i don't even understand  is okay  i uh i also know a guy who is the most  skilled plumber to run for president but  is that i mean how is that relevant to  the job it's all very strange maybe it's  just a joke i don't know but we'll  follow it